pascal thévenot bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue au bistrot du terrain jimmy je
vous en prie au bistrot du théâtre donc
pour ce nouveau numéro du café politique
nous sommes un peu loin de vos terres de
vélizy vous êtes 8,2 m c'est vrai
puisque vous êtes mère donc de vélizy et
puis député de la 2e circonscription
circonscription qui couvre une partie de
saint quentin en yvelines voisins avec
voisins et magny-les-hameaux vous êtes
arrivé donc au poste de député a tout
récemment avec le départ de valérie
pécresse on va en parler tout comme nous
allons parler aussi de votre parcours je
voudrais tout d'abord savoir un peu
comment vous avez vécu vos premiers pas
dans l'hémicycle
c'était il ya quelques semaines quelques
mois l'intégration rapide direct
dans le levage et arras qu'il a fallu
parler de la loi du nom après je pense
que c'est plus facile quand on arrive à
3 petit nouveau donc tu as le groupe
nous a accueillis et je pense que
l'intégration se fait beaucoup plus vite
alors justement vous êtes arrivé en
plein débat qui a été un petit peu
tronqué autour de cette loi du travail
une loi qui doit en plus vous intéresser
particulièrement parce que ça aussi on
en parlera mais vous êtes chef
d'entreprise
donc cette loi travail vous concerne
même directement peut-être une réflexion
une remarque sur ce recours aux 49 3
comment vous l'avez vécu a plutôt mal
mais en fait parce que tout ça pour ça
hariri la règle fait l'équipe aztèque
49,3 dès le départ comme ça on aura une
version qui est comme je la vis encore
mc j'aurais voté qui étaient plutôt
bonnes pour les entreprises là on arrive
à une version qui n'a plus rien à voir
avec l'emploi mais qui est fait pour les
syndicats et aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez que les discussions se poursuivent
les discussions les manifestations aussi
dans la rue
vous vous dites qu'ils ont raison
continuer à manifester de demander
malgré tout l'abandon de cette loi alors
raison je dirais pas ça mais que du coup
va étant donné que le grand atout le
temps écouter les syndicats étudiants à
des photos et d'écouter les salariés ou
les entrepreneurs balaban en rien les
arrête ils se disent ben voilà on a
gagné une fois deux fois trois fois
finalement c'est la loi du plus fort
on va obtenir peut-être encore d'autres
contraintes pour les entreprises
il faut continuer ou faut qu'ils
arrêtent ce mouvement parce que là c'est
déjà ça il n'aurait jamais dû avoir lieu
on a l'impression que c'est un peu les
indices tenante qui sont maintenant à
paris et puis quand on regarde l'état
d'urgence l'état d'urgence et des
rassemblements qui sont des
rassemblements en fait de casseurs de
gens quand je vois un bon point car tu
que le travail ce n'est pas fait pour
moi je pense que maintenant ben voilà il
faut assumer soit on est en état
d'urgence on ne l'est pas la
manifestation autorisée mais la casse
non est comme ça à chaque fois que de la
caf
il faut tout arrêter le gouvernement ne
doit pas céder jeudi ses arguments de
toute façon je pars du principe que
l'avion soit je ne céderai rien ou
milledge a tout cédé
donc là je pourrai d'accord avec lui
mais dans les faits c'est tout l'inversé
on voit poursuivre la conversation en
salle dans un instant juste une dernière
question vous êtes devenu maire en 2014
vous êtes député depuis cette année est
ce que ça ne va pas trop vite pour vous
ça va plus que prévu mais en fait c'est
passionnant parce que c'est en tout cas
c'est parce que j'avais imaginé ces vies
mais c'est
c'est bien complémentaires c'est
passionnant et tu vends vous avez pas
envie de faire 35 heures je pense que ça
peut être me d'être aussi précieux
pascal thévenot nous allons poursuivre
ce café politique je vous en prie
devrait se passer en salle
pascal thévenot député de la 2e
circonscription les républicains maire
de vélizy invitait donc de ce café
politique juste avant la courte pause il
était question de vos mandats de maire
et de député justement nous sommes allés
réalisé un micro-trottoir dans votre
commune de vélizy nous sommes nous allés
demander si être à la fois maire et
député donc le cumul des mandats est-ce
que c'était une bonne chose ou pas et
c'est beaucoup de travail
il faut agir la seule passe à la fois à
celui d'ici à là limite oui peut être
compatibles même si c'est un nouveau
jeune mère il n'est pas là puis il n'est
pas mère depuis longtemps mais bon pour
d'autres c'est beaucoup trop
un député maire et compagnie sénateurs
voilà ça fait beaucoup de beaucoup trop
de mandats à mon sens souhaité non je
suis désolé je pense que ans consacrent
ou à sa ville où on se consacre à être
député bon bien sûr parce que mr c'est
pour la ville et puis député c'est au
niveau national donc c'est bien je
trouve que c'est bien la voir un maire
qui fasse les deux je trouve très bien
c'est lamentable qui ferait mieux tous
deux démissionné que je suis anti
politique au maximum c'est une bande de
pourris c'est un homme capable de feu de
bois utilise les deux les deux postes
alors les avis sont partagés
j'imagine que vous allez me dire que
c'est positif forcément d'être à la fois
maire et député oui puis quand on
regarde en fait ceux qui s'intéressent
un peu la vie locale sont plutôt
favorables ce qui nous prouve tous
courir m'a paru
vouloir justement aux autres parce
qu'ils disent tous pourris tout ce qui
est aussi une partie au delà de ce micro
trottoir même sur la question du cumul
ya quand même une certaine un certain
désamour entre les politiques et les
citoyens et les électeurs donc des
échéances électorales l'année prochaine
à nouveau d'ailleurs des élections
législatives alors que je pensais que tu
as ton vrai que je vois dans une
campagne qui finalement encore et sans
fin il ya deux mois les électeurs et les
gens attendent que
10e ce confrère passe pour la vie merci
et qu'on reste à l'écouté et je pense
qu'à partir du moment où on est honnête
avec eux qu'on a on est sur nos
engagements sur ce qu'on est aussi
souvent à sa poursuite et des gens qui
défendent des politiques et défendre
autres choses qui sont vraiment je pense
que c'est l'honnêteté et l'engagement et
puis les coups tu sais que ça peut
suffire pour décider les niveaux de
faire changer la nation c'est après
l'abstention il faut que les ceux qui
sont dans la misère difficulté considère
qu'on s'occupe d'eux et qu'on arrête de
dire vous avez tort en votant des
extrêmes
tous ceux qui sont partis un moment de
soutien dans des parties que gérer
démocratique
ou de parti de gouvernement qui revient
de beauté il faut qu'ils aient
conscience que
ce qu'on propose ce qu'on fait c'est
pour eux
qui sont concernés aujourd'hui la bo
beaucoup d'eux qu'ils sont dans
l'abstention fonctions dans les extrêmes
considère qu'on s'occupe vraiment sur la
question du cumul des mandats néanmoins
et la loi est là et elle pourrait
interdire le fait d'être à la fois maire
et député si vous deviez choisir mais
j'aurais pas choisir et j'en suis je
pense que maintenant quand toujours
discutons interne cautionna il ya
la droite à la gauche qui sont qu'il
trouve que fait finalement quand on a
envie on revient sur sa au parlement on
est soixante dix poissons de mer si on
regarde bien on est trois élus restants
trois maires et c'est un sujet que je
n'ai si vous souvenez bien pour la
campagne j'avais huit candidats en face
de moi alors seule campagne a été sur le
cumul en m'insultant de temps en temps
moi j'ai affiché député-maire sur mes
affiches dans ma ville ce qui ressort un
peu de la taxe qui s'intéressent ils
étaient tous plutôt contents et
maintenant plutôt fier d'avoir un député
maire d'un circonscription plutôt
content aussi d'avoir un élu de terrain
et qui s'intéresse à eux
j'ai mis la question et je pense que
même quand je vois les lois de cho-power
tout le monde quand je peux intervenir
dans l'hémicycle
mon expérience de maire finalement aller
au real enrichi ce que je peux faire un
bond parlementaire et quand on regarde
s'il est seul
valet
les députés qui se trompent pas ta tâche
locales souvent son parachute et elle ne
s'intéresse pas du coup à la
circonscription et je pense que c'est
complémentaire en fait j'ai un
collaborateur en circonscription jean
les collaborateurs
au parlement et moi je vais jouer ce
côté bicéphale et enrichissant donc on
revient revient sur la loi vous pensez
que ça va se faire naturellement des
doutes je pense que ce sera
naturellement et que le poste de député
un principe acquis foutu mais
aujourd'hui mère je peux être
vice-président de toutes les aides aux
familles d'agglo je peux être président
de syndicat je veux je te tout cumulé et
y en a un qui est un parlementaire qui
la parole dans l'hémicycle qu'ils disent
à écouter
tout le monde peut être député sauf les
délinquants et les maires qu'en fait
ceux qui n'ont plus de droits civiques
et je pense que ça c'est
sa maman était démagogique je pense été
limité à un mandat national mandats
locaux
c'est complémentaire c'est ce que vous
nous expliquez vous êtes né en 66 vous
êtes engagés plutôt jeune en politique
vous étiez aux jeunes rpr
oui c'est bien ça avec l'appui de franck
borotra qui est l'ancien président du
conseil départemental des yvelines j'ai
débuté avec lui j'étais son délégué
jeanneret et sept jours est un de mes
modèles en connectez vous la fois chef
d'entreprise aussi qu'ils quittent
hubert
qui est qui a maintenant aurait pu être
élu encore nombreux mandats mais décide
d'arrêter appartement où il avait été
ministre a été plein de conseil général
pays considéré que tout ce qu'il avait
voulu faire passer il avait passé et ce
qui n'arrivait pas à faire passer
finalement c'était que c'était peut-être
pas la bonne personne
les sorties en haute savoie
avec cette force de servir mais dans
d'autres fonctions et à la fois pour sa
droiture son esprit poétique pour son
côté entreprise et votre engagement à
vous en politique il est venu comment
avec un moment où vous vous êtes dit je
vais rejoindre des jeunes rpr
c'est cette image s'est fait doucement
en fait je suis toujours intéressé à la
vie locale et au moment où on discutait
en sortant de l'entraînement sportif
avec humilité ans
c'est vrai qu'il m'a dit m'a tant
apporté
des sujets des principes sur mobile et
c'est là que j'ai rencontré robert
wagner
pareil à quelqu'un passionnant et puis
ensuite je me suis investi dans le monde
associatif je me suis j'ai apporté ma
vision politique à mon très longtemps je
n'étais pas encarté mais et quand les
gens disent que je côtoyais ce n'était
même pas aperçus puis jusque sur la
carte et avec franck borotra 7 au monde
jacques chirac et cet engagement ensuite
aux côtés de valérie pécresse parce
qu'elle a été très présente aussi
valérie pécresse sur la suite de votre
parcours et vous a soutenu pendant la
campagne des municipales pour le poste
de député une fois qu'elle a décidé de
partir pour la présidence de la région
ce qui a provoqué cette élection
législative sur la 2e circonscription à
quel moment vous l'avez rencontré
comment ça s'est fait qu'elles ont dès
le début en fait quand elle est arrivée
parce qu'elle était responsable
départemental aussi un donc dans les
cinémas le quota est arrivé pour ce
premier vote parlementaire sa première
campagne
elle était donnée si vous souvenez il ya
le morillon qui devait nous explose et
qui était l'oeuvre assembleur pécresse
qui arrivait et j'ai participé
s'accompagne cette remarque campagne on
n'était pas beaucoup à l'époque on était
3 4 et puis ça continue comme ça et on a
avancé dans l'ensemble on a fait tout ce
chemin rouge et directeur du service et
campagne parce que c'est pareil c'est
une famille qui écoutait vous pouvez
exprimer et puis moi j'ai toujours été
intéressée à pouvoir porter mes valeurs
et puis à les partager
pisté quelqu'un passionnant qui avait
cette force de
je travaille énormément et du coup de
temps
d'entraîner avec elle toute une équipe
et à chaque fois pour sa région pour sa
circonscription
son département pour ça pour la france
quand on regarde ça a toujours été aussi
passionné des filion d'une cote a été
mise du budget avec l'axé la crise
qu'elle ait connue
quand on est ministre l'enseignement
supérieur la recherche des lois dont on
parle et il y en a pas tant que ça même
la gauche et par un réellement robe
l'outil c'est contre j'ai eu la chance
le fait de suivre franck borotra qui
était un important valérie pécresse
pareil avec toujours ce charisme c'est
écouter puis cet enduit de servir alors
on parlait beaucoup des personnalités
politiques justement homme femme
politique est ce que certains vous
séduisent nous ont séduits à gauche l'an
d'autres familles où ça s'est toujours
naturellement porté vers la droite
serait toujours naturellement pour je
dis pas que de temps en temps on peut
voir des
les engagements qu'on partage mai
toujours porté
pécresse on disait qu'ils étaient très
présentes en 2014 lors de la campagne
municipale elle vous a soutenu
quitte à s'opposer au maire sortant le
maire sortant de vélizy dont vous étiez
l'un des adjoints d'ailleurs vous avez
décidé ensuite de vous présenter face à
lui campagne difficile
la campagne dure si on peut un peu
revenir sur cette période là alors que
les matches sont présentés il ya eu un
premier tour difficile vous êtes viré en
tête après une campagne difficile en
fait y'a pas une élection difficile mais
une campagne difficile et parce qu'en
fait la campagne moi je voulais mais je
les monnaies projet contre projet lui
j'ai eu droit à toutes les attaques
personnelles
c'est difficile quand c'est au sein de
la même famille politique c'est toujours
plus dur et pas que pour les municipales
et puis de regarder un peu histoire
jamais voulu répondre quand même fait au
niveau des équipes les pâtures passé au
niveau de ma famille quand j'ai des
attaques personnelles c
cédez pas difficile à dire moi j'ai
toujours
je n'ai jamais tenu compte toujours team
alinghi jamais répondu et je suis à la
rencontre des billysiens ça c'est ce qui
marche et puis on a réussi à faire
projet contre projet avec dix points
d'avancé au premier tour
est-ce que ça a laissé des traces même
humainement puisqu'aujourd'hui vécu
difficilement cette campagne vous y
repensez on vous dit non en 2020 je
serai candidat pour un nouveau mandat
j'espère que ça se passera
oui j'espère mais je regarde tout nu
devant rien je mets derrière donc
campagne difficile puis maintenant il y
avait un projet non parce qu'il y avait
aussi une gouvernance 1
la ville est redevenu apaisé c'était
très tendu à l'époque donc
je le vis sereinement et c'est mon
caractère fait que tout le monde salue
une ville apaisée après la france
apaisée la ville apaisée c'est aussi un
bon slogan de campagne qui consommeront
pas cette ville de vélizy vous la
connaissez depuis longtemps vous aviez
un engagement associatif vous l'avez
mentionné club de judo club de rugby
club de photographie
cette ville de vélizy vous l'avez
découverte quand vous êtes arrivé à quel
moment de votre vie
je suis né en fait j'ai toujours vécu au
niveau scolaire au niveau associatif
mais c'était une visite
c'est riche au niveau associatif puisque
déjà à mon époque il y avait énormément
de monde qui était devisé à ce type
aujourd'hui en a un sur deux c'est ce
qui fait toute sa richesse au niveau
scolaire aussi
j'appelle aux études à versailles mais
je suis toujours etc
mais mon école d'ingénieurs quand je
fais la fac c'est toujours été dans la
région
soit de versailles souhaite c'est clair
c'est
j'ai toujours été un vrai lien
juste un moment où
les pannes immobilier au fait que je me
suis je suis parti avait toujours eu
mais
s'il m'a permis d'en fait d'avoir une
bonne connaissance de la surprescription
après je veux y aller malgré tout j'ai
cité le judo j'ai cité le rugby plutôt
des sports offensive des sports de
combat c'est à l'image de la politique
parallèle et esquives et d'éviter des
coûts finalement j'ai à faire c'est un
peu ma manière de travailler c'est une
manière de travail en pack
en plus ça doit finalement c'est de
l'art alors ce territoire de vélizy et
plus globalement de la circonscription
c'était un territoire d'innovation et ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qui vous
intéresse et des grandes entreprises du
tertiaire qui sont qui sont présents
cette volonté cette implication dans ce
secteur sans parler un petit peu nous
dit que c'est quelque chose qui vous a
toujours passionné qui est l'innovation
la recherche
je pars du principe que mon rôle celui
du créer un écosystème qui permettent
aux entreprises de créer de la valeur
donc
l'élu n'a pas rentré dans la gouvernance
d'entreprise mais par contre avoir des
réseaux de transport avoir des liens
entre les entreprises à avoir du
logement et donc ça c'est tout bon rôle
souvent j'avais à dire que je suivais
rhdp je vais chercher des grands groupes
pour leur vendre ma vie mais et puis je
suis idée aussi des entreprises qui ne
l'a donc là c'est plus ma vision de chef
d'entreprise j'étais aussi très engagé
dans le monde syndical
l'entreprise c'est mettre au service mon
réseau
ma vision des choses pour en faire en
sorte que
un terrain de création de croissance et
là je suis servi parce que vélizy qui
étaient isolés
demain va pouvoir se trouver au centre
de l'environnement économique et
d'innovation vous avez paris-saclay vous
avez satory qui va se développer vous
avez saint-quentin-en-yvelines physique
il fait partie de fer sagres en
parcourant la mort précisé depuis depuis
peu finalement et puis depuis le début
de l'année et puis à ce secteur de
satory qui effectivement connaître je
fais petit pot est un projet fabuleux
paris-saclay aussi vous avez ordi
derrière donc là on peut vraiment faire
un territoire tels que la tv comme valet
ou un lieu de recherche d'innovation et
de création de richesses donc des
créations d'emplois justement il en
manque aux entreprises aujourd'hui parce
que vous avez à la fois cette casquette
de chef d'entreprise veut s'y impliquer
dans la vie de l'entreprise
ce que vous êtes d'ailleurs encore
toujours chefs d'entreprise n'ont enlevé
le temps vous avez dit souhaiter tout ça
est justement qu'est ce qui manque aux
entreprises pour pouvoir embaucher
pouvoir créer de l'emploi parce qu'on
voit le chômage qui progresse
la confiance vient comporte aujourd'hui
vous apercevez que
il ya des investisseurs tels dangereux
mais
c'était un peu tout but de la loi sur le
travail ses drones et de confiance
puisque aujourd'hui je m'aperçois qu'il
ya des petites entreprises qui ont peur
de kruth et simplement vous répondra à
marcher à une commande et du coup ne
voient pas leur chiffre d'affaires
se développer alors si elle a des
confiance elle pourrait embaucher une
personne pour répondre à un appel
d'offres justement quand on répond quand
on se donne on l'a on l'obtient et pour
développer de la caussenarde j'ai une
force d'attentes
l'entreprise qu'elle souhaite c'est moi
que j'étais chef d'entreprise la loi
qu'elle soit faite à droite ou à gauche
qu'on n'ait jamais affrontée avec comme
une vision et mon but c'était
d'anticiper une m'adapter et alors que
là aujourd'hui la réalité d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas arrêté de demain donc du coup
une flexibilité mémos classés la
flexibilité oui flexibilité mais surtout
c'est a beau avoir la visibilité à long
terme
dire qu'on fait que la loi soit pendu
quand même il faut pas qu'elle change
tous les jours on quitte pour être un
petit peu de cette vie locale et puis
cette ville de l'assemblée puisque vous
prenez position aussi sur des questions
d'ordre national au niveau du choix pour
le candidat de la primaire de la droite
et du centre votre candidat c'est
françois fillon pour la présidentielle
de 2017
pourquoi françois fillon qui au gré des
sondages varie entre le 3e 4e place
oui alors après on pourra parler de la
place en fait je le connaissais comme
tout le monde
avant d'être élu mais la manière dont il
portait les choses son analyse en faites
moi ce qui m'a séduit
chez lui c'est un bon diagnostic and
remise en compte aussi de ses erreurs
quand il était premier ministre et l'
envie de dire clairement que ça plaise
ou pas ses engagements son programme
avant l'élection pour pouvoir être
légitime et le porter tout de suite et
que les 100 jours ça soit pas simplement
un slogan mais ça soit réellement
l'utilité l'attendent aujourd'hui
défoncé moi je vois même nom ma campagne
électorale
les gens étaient prêts à des réformes
puisque toute façon aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'on va dans le mur
nous les expliquerons les met dans un
ensemble avec une vision de ciel bleu
derrière les buts ce n'est pas la forme
dur pour des réformes dures et c'est le
seul qui est capable de ça et ensuite
quand j'ai été élu j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir tous les candidats au téléphone
de les voir le seul tu m'as pas parler
de lui mais qui s'intéressait à ce que
penser
les citoyens
les électeurs que j'avais rencontré
pendant trois mois si vous voulez avoir
une analyse autres voir mon ami du chef
d'entreprise et c'est lui et maintenant
que j'ai appris je travaille plus
souvent avec lui que je suis plus au
quotidien avec lui finalement l'homme
que je connaissais pas m'a encore plus
chez lui je suis encore plus motivé et
vous aujourd'hui il est
hier troisième
mettez de côté bruno le maire qui est
pourtant est pas très bon ministre un
épiphénomène pour mais c'est sévère
s'est créé de très critique épiphénomène
c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau donc non
je dis pas que mais on ne peut pas
défendre un personnage connaît pas et
quand bruno qui a plein de qualités on a
le maire explique oui bah écoutez
regardez il faut essayer parce qu'on a
tout essayé
lui il a fait des cabinets de
il a fait tout ça car dans des cabinets
de mystère et quantifie explique nuit je
suis seul à avoir démissionné la
sanction de huis clos c'est fait
françois fillon peut pas le faire elle a
jamais été fonctionnaire
bon après voilà c'est un faucon défendre
un projet mais qu'avec une personnalité
qu'on a un qui est pas tord mais non
c'est pas méchant c'est que chacun
apportera des choses et françois fillon
peut refaire son retard et demi journées
nature depuis la traque aux usa on
appelle moi je suis impressionné
vous avez côtoyé aussi nicolas sarkozy
je pense que je voulais pas en cause ce
qu'il a fait dans une situation
difficile où on
on s'en est pas si mal sorti comment son
quinquennat aujourd'hui que ce soit
juste ou pas juste vous avez peur vous
êtes sortant vous avez perdu
vous apportez votre pierre à l'édifice
mais
c'est compliqué de repartir et je vois
aujourd'hui les tous les électeurs j'ai
pu roi et côtoyé pendant ma campagne
ils sont passés à autre chose mais c'est
malgré tout le président des
républicains aujourd'hui c'est un bon
président c'est un bon président pour
les républicains
oui là il a organisé la primaire il
porte des idées ils portent le débat
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il peut apporter
ces
sa contribution à ça mais si on se
retrouve les gens veulent pas rejouer le
match
hollande sarkozy ici on à hollande
sarkozy tout peut arriver
je pense que voilà et puis
fillon aujourd'hui c'est plus facile de
faire de la com
une fois qu'on a un bon projet que de
faire de la communication sans projet
huilez d'avec le projet sa part c'est de
l'art met en doute
il est porté là dessus il va maintenant
il faut vendre le produit
et ça je pense qu'il sait faire et même
les journalistes qui nous suivaient ont
été souvent surpris par le nombre de
personnes qui l'entouraient quand il a
réalisé tous ses soutiens tous ces
comités de soutien équilibre pour
travailler tout samedi matin il y avait
mille personnes amen puis elle est chef
d'entreprise ya beaucoup de chômeurs
parce que ça derrière lui la campagne
est persuadé que toute façon c'est le
seul fait qu'on regretterait la france
et puis
quand un de vos confrères me disait même
ont pourtant on en réponse et vous allez
vous revoir juppé parce que a débuté
c'est plus facile et c'est celui qui
pourrait avec impression de gagner moi
je pars du principe que c'est plutôt mes
idées mes valeurs qui doivent être
portées
et puis par contre après j'ai pas
l'habitude de perdre donc je pense qu'il
va gagner on va écouter juste un micro
trottoir pour terminer sur cette
question et françois fillon est il le
meilleur des candidats et côté
il a déjà prouvé pendant cinq ans il n'a
pas fait grand chose donc voilà faut
qu'il laisse la place aux autres
maintenant la ccl super aléatoire je ne
pense pas je vois la chair je laisse
encore avoir le programme comment ça va
se passer
c'est toute une histoire tout ça en fait
un alors là je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas du tout oui y'a pas mieux je pense
je sais pas et là tellement gros cpu est
las de trop il n'a peut-être encore qui
vont se présenter
pourquoi pas c'est un peu un peu correct
où je sais pas comment pas en ce moment
ça se bouscule un suivi qui a les
meilleures idées sortira en sortira
vainqueur
oui je quand même de la sympathie pour
lui oui oui je reconnais je reconnais a
bêtement et encore c'est que les gens
sont pas dans la primaire fait on n'est
pas encore entre conjoints
ça va réellement démarré septembre pour
avoir qui reste vraiment dida parce
qu'il faut aussi la patrie ciel
manquants mais il est clair que même pas
campagne
c'est ce qui m'avait demandé d'ailleurs
entretenu la primaire j'ai mais personne
n'en parle aujourd'hui tout en chemin et
et oui ça par contre ça reflète assez
bien voilà c'est loin il ya pas de
personnage et je pense que entre
c'est comme un produit qu'on a le bon
produit il faut le rendre vous
et là maintenant il ya tout bête c'est
ce qui fait ils organisent
il fait des propositions
sont tout le temps assez consensuel mais
fort mais oui là
on en parlera après l'été et la suite
pour vous parce que 2017 sera à nouveau
des élections législatives j'y retourne
candidats dont j'ai un petit cd
également à l'essai pendant là non
je serai candidat c'est acté oui c'est
acté sa jamais tôt mis en doute
non je me serais pas présenté pour un an
et puis je vois là en plus dans
l'opposition j'espère dans la majorité
plus tard j'ai apporté encore plus de
projets à avoir plus de contribution à
faire et aussi regard de mon expérience
d'entreprise pour faire progresser un
pays
à
jv passionnés merci et pascal thévenot
invitait donc de ce café politique
merci à vous